Fox News Alert president Trump naming
advisers who will guide efforts to
reopen the US economy as all 50 states
are now under a disaster declaration for
the first time in history chief White
House correspondent John Roberts is live
with more on all of that hey good
morning John Sandra good morning to you
again we'll give you the latest on the
new Council to reopen America in a
second but first of all within the last
half hour the president tweeting that
when it comes to reopening the United
States economy the decision will be his
and his alone the president tweeting
quote for the purpose of creating
conflict and confusion some of the fake
news media are saying that it is the
governor's decision to open up the
state's not that of the President of the
United States and the federal government
let it be fully understood that this is
incorrect it is the decision of the
President and for many good reasons with
that being said the administration and I
are working closely with the governors
and this will continue a decision by me
in conjunction with the governor's an
input from others will be made shortly
the president scheduled to announce
tomorrow the makeup and the creation of
his new council to reopen America it
looks like at this point there are only
government people who were involved in
this nobody from the outside among the
people who will be on the council it
will be chaired by mark meadows the
White House chief of staff it will also
include Ivanka Trump Jared Kushner
Treasury secretary minuchin Larry Kudlow
is chief economic adviser Robert light
Heiser the US Trade Representative the
secretaries of Commerce agriculture
transportation energy labor HUD the OMB
director and the chairman of the Council
of Economic Advisers along with a couple
of other people the next soft target for
reopening is now May the 1st but as the
FDA Administrator dr. Stephen Hahn says
it's one that will ultimately depend on
conditions being right for a reopening
listen here it is a target and obviously
we're hopeful about that target but I
think it's just too early to be able to
tell that we see light at the end of the
tunnel dr. Fauci dr. Burks have said
that we see the incredible resiliency of
the American people with respect to
social distancing the president said
last Friday that making the decision on
what to do will be the
most difficult decision he has ever
faced ever not just as president the
white house trade advisor Peter Navarro
says it's a difficult calculus because
there are enormous pressures on both
sides of the equation listen here we
know that the virus itself kills but we
also know that economic recessions and
depressions kill and so that very tough
decision this president is going to be
making is to have to have to weigh the
balance and figure out which which path
does more damage and the president
continuing to push back against reports
that he ignored warnings in late January
from Navarro and others that the virus
could be devastating if it were to
spread widely in this country the
president pointing out his early move to
stop travel from China was important and
also tweeted quote I was criticized for
moving too fast when I issued the China
ban long before most others wanted to do
so secretary azar told me nothing until
later and the Peter Navarro memo was the
same as the ban see his statements fake
news the president is likely expected to
leave the coronavirus daily briefing
this afternoon at 5 o'clock ish I will
likely learn more about the makeup of
the council what he expects to happen
and whether or not they will be able to
begin reopening government in just a
little more than two weeks Sandra we
will look forward to that John Roberts
at the White House thank you John